loves these performance in The Shining I
mean a lot of people do a lot of people
say that's the best shining uh uh any
fun stories and did you meet Stephen
King while filming now I know you did a
bunch of stuff with Stephen King like a
bunch of audio books so he must have
really liked you yes uh and you still
talk to him uh you know I haven't uh we
we have had a few email exchanges over
the years but he's uh he's on a
different planet you know he's on planet
King but he was around a lot during the
filming of The Shining and I was able to
ask him questions because I was reading
the book while doing it and I even
remember if you have two seconds uh that
I there was a portion of the book that I
I couldn't understand it was like a
little triplet or something like that
and I asked him what it meant I thought
oh great I've got a living author
downstairs what does this mean Steve and
basically he was like yeah this line um
is about a bottle of wine this is
because I was standing over a carpet and
it had a color that intrigued me and
this I was drunk
and I was like oh thanks Steve I was
hoping for something a little more
profound really deep no he was a great
guy he's fantastic did he Express on The
Shining how UNS dissatisfied is the
right word right thank you uh he was
with the original shining the Kubrick he
did I mean he was he was philosophical
about it I think he was he was
ultimately disappointed that a filmmaker
like Kubrick
made it kind of boulderized King's work
it was in effect Stanley Kubrick's
version of uh The Shining as opposed to
Stephen King's shining I never read the
book is it way different well it's
fantastic because ultimately as scary uh
and Fantastical as it is you can see
that it's about alcoholism it's about
the dissolution of a family it's about
Redemption it's about all the things
that you don't associate with monsters
or Stephen King and the books and the
stories that I've read of his are almost
all about that even something as epic as
as the the book it
it's yes it's about Pennywise the Clown
and it's terrifying and all this stuff
but it's about so much more so um was it
taxing on you to do that part taxing I
mean
maybe not taxing enough because uh
apropos what I was talking about before
I I really wish I could go back with
what I know now about myself and about
what it's like to be a a flawed human
being and attack those scenes again it
wasn't taxing I was having too much fun
I was too excited to be there you know
and it's actually it's good it's more
than good uh the the king faithful
prefer it to Kubrick's film but the
Kubrick film obviously is a this iconic
do you both love The Shining the
original shining I love you yeah it's a
great movie it's not Stephen King's
movie best moment in The Shining in uh
the Kubrick film yeah
oh my god oh look what's terrifying is
when they're he's walking up the stairs
and he's and he's talking to Wendy and
she is
she's not given way she's not given
nearly enough credit I mean she's been
denigrating yeah she is so rung out rung
out and out of her mind with and we've
heard all these stories but it's
fantastic it's fantastic but look but
you know the the my hang up with that
with Jack Nicholson at that point was
that he was playing something that was
almost like amusement park size but
guy's great it happened really fast yeah
yeah what's yours I um
I I just immediately went to uh to the
scene with Lloyd the bartender oh yeah
I'm the kind of guy likes to know who's
buying his drinks Lloyd I don't know why
that line I love what he says it's
momentary Labs
my favorite as he knows is when she
comes because yeah Jackson was in the
hotel they heard Danny and he goes
you out of your [__] mind yeah yeah